keeping it simple in the kitchen doesn't
mean you can't have amazing food that
not only looks incredible but tastes
fantastic too
my first recipe is so easy it removes
the stress from cooking and is a
pleasure to make chili beef lettuce
wraps
cooking should never be a chore the more
you cook the more confident you become
that way you actually start to enjoy it
and that's the key to good cooking have
a bit of fun along the
way this is minced beef and minced pork
the pork needs to sit in there otherwise
the beef's gonna dry out
it's really important to season the
mince before you cook it
pan nice and hot
a touch of olive oil
mince in
breaking up like that really helps to
sort of separate it so we can fry it off
with a lot of color
with your spoon
just go through
and start breaking that up
the most important thing to remember is
mint is made up of cheap cuts brisket
belly
short rib so
it needs help
and frying off the mince for color
it's so important
if this pan wasn't hot your mince is
going to boil it's a horrible gray color
on there
and there's no flavor on your mince
taste a little bit
[Music]
tastes delicious it's seasoned
beautifully see how crispy it's going
take it
much further than you ever taken mince
before nice and crispy
smells incredible
i'm draining it it's crucial it keeps
the mints nice and crispy and you get
rid of that
excess fat
that's lovely
now
just wipe out the pan then wash it low
gas
now we're going to add texture to the
mince
finely chopped chili
ginger
garlic and spring onions
spring onions give this sort of mince a
really nice freshness
because it just gives that crunch
nice and thinly
now i'm gonna fry off the chilis the
ginger the garlic first
sesame seed oil teaspoon only in
garlic chili ginger in
fry that off nicely
the sesame seed oil just lifts up the
whole flavour
brown sugar that starts to really
caramelize the chili the garlic and the
ginger
mince in
now
my fish sauce that gives it the
saltiness
you can see now why it's so important to
get that mince really crispy because
nothing's going soggy staying really
crispy
fresh lime
that makes the mince fragrant
and then
lime juice roll it
and squeeze that in there
[Music]
incredible i've got the salty
i've got the heat
i've got the sweetness now i've got the
acidicness as well and then finally my
spring onions in right at the last
minute so i've got crunch in there as
well
smells
amazing literally cook the mince now
with sort of 30 seconds
to go
off and take it out
looks incredible smells so inviting
[Music]
to go with the chili beef i'm making a
simple sweet and spicy dipping sauce so
everyone can dress the crispy mince to
their own taste
dipping sauce a little teaspoon
the brown sugar soy sauce
gives it a nice sort of dark rich color
sesame seed oil
a tablespoon and just top that up with a
tablespoon
of olive oil
that stops the sesame seed all becoming
too rich a teaspoon
of fish sauce and then a touch of chili
leave the seeds in again i want the heat
in that sauce
so impressive an amazing show off center
piece
lime juice
in
in the coriander chop it through once
give that little mix up
just check the seasoning
that's lovely nice and rich
now the lettuce i'm going to use baby
gem because it's really nice and durable
and sort of quite strong
so you just sort of sit
these nice
trimmed lettuce leaves
around
now the exciting part to serve take your
lettuce up
spoon in
your mince and then
a little touch of dressing
just a little drizzle
nice and that's the secret of having
good easy relaxed food is that
you just help yourself
food that looks and tastes a million
bucks doesn't have to be complex
this dish is as fun to cook as it is to
eat
[Music]
my next easy recipe is a miniature
version of an american favorite the
burger smokey pork sliders with barbecue
sauce
everyone loves a burger they're a true
fast food original and that's the
exciting thing about street food you can
take an old classic like that and
reinvent it into something really
exciting
when you think of a burger what you need
is a great sauce an unlike smoky
barbecue goes hand in glove with a great
burger
start by finely chopping one onion and
three cloves of garlic
nice hot pan tablespoon of olive oil
onions and garlic into the pan
nice seasoning salt and pepper
now the secret of a good barbecue sauce
is that really important caramelization
to begin with a nice tablespoon of brown
sugar
it darkens the onions but it really
starts to sort of give that nice syrupy
body to the
sauce i put a little bit of heat in
there now a nice teaspoon of smoked
paprika
that's the important part of working
with spices you got to cook them out and
almost sort of burn off that rawness
especially with a smoked paprika that's
exactly where i want it to go
onions and garlic beautifully
caramelized
cider vinegar in
reduce that down
now i've got a fantastic smoky base to
complete the sauce i'm making my life
really easy and adding pre-made
worcester sauce and tomato ketchup cook
that out for two to three minutes
now depending on how thick you like the
barbecue sauce that determines how long
you cook it out for i don't want it to
be too
runny but i don't want it too thick
either
that's the consistency we're looking for
lovely
turn down the gas
chapter seasoning
now
take that out
it's the kind of sauce that i like to
have sort of bottled up in the fridge
it's great for sandwiches
but goes brilliantly well with these
sliders
homemade smoky barbecue sauce
[Music]
give the pan a little wipe
now start the mix for the sliders to
give my mix a really interesting flavor
and texture i'm gonna be using unsmoked
back bacon i
travel
all over the world
and i spend a lot of time in the states
they know how to make a great slider
pork sliders beef sliders chicken
sliders
it's almost like a way of having a
burger
but on a much smaller miniature level
a little teaspoon of olive oil
i want that bacon to get really nice and
crispy
bacon in
this just gives the really nice sort of
chunky delicious mix i want texture
and pork is perfect for a slider
[Music]
and choppy shallot
shallots are a lot sweeter than your
normal white onion
fine fine fine and then
[Music]
now that bacon's getting really nice and
crispy i want a bit of heat in there
put a little teaspoon
of smoked paprika in there
when you see these sliders in the states
for one portion there's like four or
five of them little mini
one biters incredible
now take your pork just open up
and give that a really nice seasoning
so important you can't season a slider
after you've cooked it it's impossible
so
season it nicely
bake
now that's nice and crispy
just take a little touch
kitchen roll and just drain that off
there
nice
pat that
nice and dry i want all that nice sort
of crispiness
in there
beautiful mix all that
in
take
a nice ball and sort of
roll it
the size of a golf ball
get it nice and round first and then
three fingers
just pat that down
don't flatten them too thin otherwise
they overcook and they go
sort of dry
because sliders are bite-sized burgers
designed to go in small buns you don't
want to make them too big
good
get the pan nice and hot a tablespoon of
olive oil
when a slider is literally that thick
about an inch thick
we're going to take two and a half to
three minutes to each side
in
turn them over
lovely
once you've turned them tilt the pan and
just spoon
all that juice back into them
keep my mouth watering now
very easy to dry the pork out so just
feeling it now your fingers is nice and
firm
it's a little touch of springiness in
the center i'm happy with those
add your cheese now so it gets nicely
melted i'm using wedgies of smoked
cheddar
and it has that nice sort of soury smoky
creaminess to the slider
finally shredded baby gem lettuce
just take those buns
make sure they're sliced
nice and evenly
take your lettuce be quite generous with
the lettuce
just a nice thin slice
of tomato
take your burgers
you see that cheese
melted your bbq sauce
place the top on
and that is my version of a slider that
is small dynamic but packed full of
flavor i'll take that over a hamburger
any day
beef tacos with wasabi mayo
the great thing about street food is
anything goes the only rule is they've
got to be really fast and really tasty
now these tacos mix a mexican and
japanese flavours into a delicious meaty
mouthful
first off get that pan really nice and
hot
these are
sirloin steaks
sear it in the pan with all that fat on
i'll add flavor
salt and pepper
couple tablespoons of olive oil in
pan
nice and hot hold up the steak
and lay it in always lay away
give the pan a
little shake and it stops the steak from
sticking we're looking for color
and if it sticks it's gonna burn
while the steaks are cooking i can get
on with my super quick marinade
now
two tablespoons of
misood paste that's a fermented soybean
that gives a really nice sort of rich
sweetness
tablespoon of sugar
a couple of tablespoons rice wine that
gives it a really nice vinegary kick a
couple of tablespoons of olive oil
salt and
pepper i'm looking for a nice sort of
thick
rich marinade
marinade done it's time to turn the
steaks
sort the pan
and to give the steaks a little baste
all we're doing every time is just
adding more and more flavor
take your tongs and sort of lift the
steak on its back and really
melt all that fat down
off of the gas
take them out
just take your knife
see all that fat there just slice that
off
i don't want any of that
now
in
to the marinade
[Music]
beautiful
tacos are one of mexico's most popular
street foods they've been made from beef
pork chicken or fish and are loaded up
with amazing sauces and spices
now i want something sort of pickly
cabbage
these are
um chinese cabbages slice it in half
look at it really crisp and really tasty
we're gonna slice that into quarters
and then just shred it and take your
time
think of cabbage here and you think of
sort of braised
overcooked cabbage nothing worse
but at a taco you want freshness
a little season of chili flakes
they sort of discreetly
give it a little bit of heat
a little touch
of rice wine vinegar
if you haven't got that fresh lemon
juice
a small drop of toasted sesame seed oil
give that
a really good mix
now i need something to sort of bring it
together we take some wasabi paste very
hot very spicy a sort of thumbnail size
i'm gonna mix that
with a couple of tablespoons of
mayonnaise
and give that a really good mix
these are basic corn tortilla the trick
is
to sort of color them
and then shape them
actually place it
on the gas ring
use some tongs
so it's not to burn yourself
you can also toast your tacos in a
frying pan
from there
i'm just gonna place it
on the rolling pin
literally 30 seconds
as it cools down
the great thing about serving tacos is
people can fill them themselves just the
way they want them cabbage
just squeeze out wet marinade
a nice rustic little mountain
mayonnaise
on
wait you see
how soft
and delicious and almost sort of
melting in the mouth texture we've got
on this amazing sirloin
look at that really nice
sear around the outside
it's just nice and pink in the middle
start off with my
crispy shell
back of the spoon with the wasabi
mayonnaise
inside taco
and just sprinkle
that delicious
pickled cabbage
and then just
start lining my taco three or four
slices
a touch more
on my spicy
layer
and that is how i'd make
the perfect taco
[Music]
you